club Anthony Richard pre-party 1503 this
mindful brain the Conservative Party
candidate 16,600 Keaton Sally Labour
Party 13
partisan Mary Angela Liberal Democrats
1401 UK 6,000
spies for voting for more candidates and
voters was entitled to 23 and for being
unlocked by holding Voyager uncertainty
89 other categories were zero the total
112 turn out 66 point eighty five
percent I do hereby declare that Michael
to Rome Ellis is chilly
thank you very much indeed can I take
this opportunity to thank the returning
officer and his staff everyone here this
evening for their excellent work and
calls the police for their work this
evening can I also take this opportunity
to express my deep gratitude to my
campaign manager Daisy Peck I think just
about the youngest
with all my campaign start my volunteers
and my staff Andrew stone q4 battalion
are the people who have helped me and
helped my constituents I am extremely
grateful it's humbling to represent the
town where I was born and brought up
I've lived my whole life it's been a
signal honor for me over the past five
years and I undertake out do my very
best over the next department to serve
people of internal thank you very much
you